أجنبي
هذا سيعمل حقًا وهذا من شأنه أن
ينقذ الأرواح ويكون فائدة كبيرة في
حالات الإصابات الجماعية
[موسيقى] إنه
أمر مذهل، بدأ المشروع
معنا بشكل أساسي في الطابق السادس من
مسكني ونأكل الكعك ونعمل على
هذا في عالمنا
الرجولي
[  الموسيقى]
عندما تشرح الفكرة بشكل صحيح، يبدو الأمر
كما لو أنك وضعت
ساعة Apple Watch أو Fitbit على جندي ثم
قمت بوضع شاشة عليها بشكل صحيح ولكن كيف
يمكنك بالضبط إنشاء Fitbit بحيث
يمكنك بشكل أساسي إيقاف تشغيل
الصفر الكهرومغناطيسي الصامت تمامًا  الإشعاع حتى
تعرف أن الجندي والجندي المصاب
لا يصبح في الأساس منارة EMF عملاقة
تقول مرحبًا أنا هنا. تم
إنشاء هذه المستشعرات لتكون
مدمجة ومقاومة للماء، بل يمكن
تطهيرها ولا تزال تعمل،
وتوجد مستشعرات المستندات في هذه المعادن
القطع وهناك أيضا البطارية وهي الجزء
الأكبر والأثقل وجهاز
الإرسال
هنا نرى أه موقع
الجنود على الخريطة وإذا كان الجميع
بخير فالجميع باللون الأزرق وعند حدوث
إصابة أو شخص ما
سيؤرخ  يتغير لون النقطة بواسطة
الفاصل الأجنبي
على مدار مسيرتي المهنية، لقد كنت
مسعفًا في الخطوط الأمامية أعالج المرضى
في ساحة المعركة في
كل مستوى، وأستطيع أن أرى أنه إذا كان لدي هذه
الأداة، ففي ذلك الوقت كانت
ستساعدني كممارس سريري وأنا'  أنا
متأكد من أنه سيكون مفيدًا لكل من هو
موجود هناك